president-elect joe biden tearing into
president trump as democrats march
toward a
second impeachment nancy pelosi and her
party have been demanding
vp mike pence invoke the 25th amendment
to remove
trump from office after the chaos at the
capitol
and if that doesn't happen they're going
to impeach trump for a second time
house democrats are drafting articles
and they could introduce them as early
as monday
joe biden going after president trump
and says he
won't stand in congress's way if they
try to throw trump out of office
watch what the congress decides to do
is for them to decide what
this president has done has ripped the
band-aid all the way off
to let the country know who he is and
what he's about
and how thoroughly unfit for office he
is
he's one of the most incompetent
presidents in the history of the united
states of america
and so the idea that i think he
shouldn't be out of office yesterday
is not the issue he indicated he wasn't
going to show up at the uh
at the inauguration one of the few
things he and i have ever agreed on
he's been an embarrassment to the
country
embarrassed us around the world not
worthy not worthy to hold that office
if we were six months out we should be
moving
everything to get him out of office and
teaching him again
invoke trying to invoke the 25th
amendment whatever it took
to get him out of office but i am
focused now
on us taking control as president and
vice president
on the 20th the white house responding
with a new
statement quote as president trump said
yesterday this is a time for healing
and unity as one nation a politically
motivated impeachment against a
president
with 12 days remaining in his term will
only serve to further
divide our great country greg
i can't jill biden is the leader of the
democratic party and president-elect
just tell
congress to knock it off there's 12 days
left
what are we doing why divide the country
even more
well uh so far as the captain divide
the captain uniter he's doing a terrible
job i mean already
he says the cops are racist because they
were soft on white protesters
i wondered did he feel that maybe they
should kill another
another protester one wasn't enough and
his logic there was idiotic
because we saw uh he said that uh if
they were black lives matter protesters
they would have been treated differently
we saw the riots that were part of the
dem those demonstrations
and we saw how rioters and looters were
treated with our own eyes
so i don't know i mean we've never seen
this kind of thing before
in our history i believe because i don't
think we've ever seen this kind of
conflict
or this kind of president an outs an
outsider
that is completely despised by the
political establishment
and by the way it's it's a system not a
bug
we know that we know what he is but he
isn't incompetent he isn't incompetent
he is inflammatory but i think we got to
get ready
for the next game and that is the uh the
domestic
war on terror right so that we have uh
democratic politicians
claiming now that the single greatest
national security threat
is domestic terror and they're gonna be
used using wednesday
as their uh their reasoning and their
fuel for this
not jazz not portland not antifa not the
riots over the summer but this
particular event and they're gonna use
that as a crusade
to go after i believe people whose
opinions
will not match there so that's the thing
i as as uh
as congressman i think congress person
slotkin is she a congress person
i think she's a congressperson said the
post 9 11 era is over
saying that it's no longer about
international terror but domestic terror
so look out for yeah they're teeing this
up for uh political crackdown
dana is this how it's gonna be now you
know joe's just gonna say uh
congress can do what they want and
they're going to run the show
i would expect someone like joe biden
who considers himself
a statesman to rise above this pettiness
an impeachment with 12 days left and say
hey guys let's just move
on i at least that's what i expected
joe biden to say
well he you know he he said a lot of
those things up until i
i think wednesday changed a lot of
opinions and minds
and that it was so catastrophic that
maybe it's just hard to think about you
know healing
at the moment i'm for it i would love
that
i would like for everybody to get along
i remember barbara bush used to say the
best way for a marriage to work is for
both parties to be willing to go 65
of the way there um that's not where we
are right now just in reality
we can hope for it we can do that in our
own lives right
but when it comes to this one i think it
would be worse if joe biden was telling
congress
and urging them to do this i think that
nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
feel like you know they've got a role to
play here and they want consequences
and punishment for what happened on
wednesday
one thing i was surprised about in joe
biden's speech today
in addition to saying that he is glad
that the president's not coming to
his inauguration i can understand that's
fine
but he keeps referring back to the obama
biden administration
and as if that he has the same kind of
mandate
that barack obama had which he doesn't
um barack obama had
60 democrats in the senate joe biden has
50.
he does not have the rhetorical gifts
even in his prime that
barack obama has and he's talking about
an agenda that is just
not going to be possible with a 50 50
split
so i thought there were several
discordant things in that speech today
including that uh katie and it's it's
not like the republican party
and elected republican officials are
defending anything that happened on
wednesday
i mean there's been universal
condemnation across the board
so for for joe biden and nancy pelosi to
just try to drive a stake
through the heart of of president trump
and all of his supporters
which will be meaningless it'll only
further inflame the country
just it just doesn't seem like a
responsible act
do you agree with that i do agree with
that i think it's obvious now that joe
biden wasn't actually being honest with
the american people when he said he
wanted to be
a unifier and i think people would take
the democrats impeachment efforts a lot
more seriously if they hadn't been
trying to impeach him
and remove him from office for since the
day he was
he won the election in 2016. you know
president trump was a dually elected
president for four years
we had an election in november that joe
biden won there are 12 days to go
and it's the left never seems to learn
their lesson when it comes to how we got
trump
in the first place which makes me think
that they're doing it on purpose to
continue
to stoke this incivility between the
right and the left
you know they're turning him into a
martyr on his way out
uh and i'm telling you it's not gonna
make the situation any better you know
nancy pelosi wants to impeach him
because she wants to
keep him from running in 2024 which
it's obvious to me that he's still a
threat to their political
you know process and ambitions in
washington um but if the left really
wanted to make trump go away
uh they would be just going through the
next 12 days
not talking about him uh and and trying
to move forward with preventing
what happened at the capitol on
wednesday
yeah they're out for blood and they're
trying to embarrass them and there's no
way they can get two-thirds in the
senate anyway
um and what are they going to talk about
when he's gone i i don't
that the hate has to to flow somewhere
juan give me a yes or no
okay do you think juan williams
impeaching president trump next week
is good for the country or bad for the
country
oh it's good for the country jesse i
think that you know
you the timing is the problem i mean
as i think you said at the start we have
about 12 days left before the
inauguration of joe biden
and you know you know something so
consequential
being rushed is the issue but i don't
think there's any question that
as far as the founding fathers were
concerned the
idea of high crimes and misdemeanors
is definitely met by inciting a mob to
go attack the capital of the united
states and stop a constitutional process
certification of an election so i don't
think there's any doubt that's what the
founding fathers had in mind and what he
did
was so outrageous i mean that's you know
to me there has to be consequences you
can't
just say oh well we'll forget about it
let's normalize it what's the big deal
it's not to talk about what joe biden
said or what joe biden promised in terms
of healing
what we've got to talk about is somebody
who in the
the chief executive of our country the
president
who would do such a reprehensible act as
incite a mob to attack other politicians
uh you know even to condemn his own vice
president as lacking courage and
i mean it's just it's just unfathomable
it's unbelievable so yes if people say
there has to be consequences i fully
understand it
and you might even say that's part of
the healing process
is that we do understand that when
people
do something that leads to the death of
a capitol hill policeman when you have
his own cabinet fleeing members of the
white house staff running out the door
that's not because of joe biden making
some comment
that's because of the actions of donald
trump
here's the issue though jesse let me
just say something
impeachment is meaningless when you've
been pushing it
for five years you were pushing for
impeachment before he was elected
so the fact that you've been crying wolf
so much it really doesn't matter
it's not about healing it's a
vindictiveness and you didn't mention
the republicans resigning and i think
it's a good point to bring up this
virtue signaling
no one these republicans calling for
impeachment or resigning
no one is going to change their minds
about you
if they already hate you it's too late
adam kinzinger or mitt romney it's too
late for you guys
to make new friends okay